guys I saw it it's alive it's huge look
at look at it it's humongous I can't I
can't believe it
it's alive it's huge so big look at it
clearly clearly alive and huge it's so
huge and alive 10 Cloverfield Lane stars
mary elizabeth winstead as a girl who
wakes up in an underground bomb shelter
she discovers she's been taken there by
John Goodman who claims that there is no
way they can leave because the air
outside is not breathable so we have
this guy keeping this girl captive or is
he actually helping her is there really
a problem outside can the air be breathe
or is this guy just insane
either way this girl has to figure out
what's going on so I'm kind of a
gigantic Cloverfield fan I feel like I'm
one of the only people that genuinely
loved that first film I actually don't
have much of a visual memory for seeing
transformers in theaters and that's
because the thing I remember most about
that night was that crazy trailer for
Cloverfield that blew everyone away got
people talking and the brilliant viral
marketing campaign afterwards that I was
hooked on I remember those days the
heydays of the Cloverfield IMDB message
boards tons of fun that film was made in
secret and they somehow did it again I
personally wouldn't call this film a
sequel in fact I think it would be a
mistake to go into this film expecting a
sequel this is a confined claustrophobic
tension-filled thriller that's what this
movie is and if you go into this movie
knowing that I think you're gonna love
it because I kind of did in fact as soon
as it was over I wanted to see it again
instantaneously so let's talk about the
pros of this movie because there are
some cons and I'll get into those
towards the end of this review pros man
Dan Trachtenberg as a director hats off
to you man this is your first feature
film and I can't wait to see what else
you do this film was filled with tension
and suspense this film there is
definitely a vibe throughout the
majority of it where you're thinking to
yourself this is all completely
realistic and tangible I could easily
see some guy going
absolutely batshit insane and chaining a
woman and a man up in a basement
somewhere because he's positive that
something else is up there that we have
to stay away from which leads me to my
next favorite thing about this film and
that is John Goodman this guy is a class
act he is one of the best character
actors alive hands down and the reason
his performance is so good in this movie
is because we as the viewer are unable
to figure out exactly what's going on in
his mind the movie toys with us so
excellently and it's a great example of
misdirection we never really know is he
really insane or is he on the level in
one scene he may appear subtly crazy but
in the next he is completely rational
you never fully know what's going on in
his head which makes our hero played by
Mary Elizabeth Winstead constantly on
edge and she gave the best performance
I've ever seen from her and one of the
things that I adored about her character
is that she's not an idiot she's really
smart she's really clever usually in
horror thrillers like this you're
screaming at the screen you're dumb why
are you doing that stop don't go in
there don't go over there just pick up
that thing do the thing that we know you
should do but you're not doing not in
this film she is a head of the audience
the film wisely presents small clues in
just brief shots or perhaps a small line
of dialogue a book on a shelf maybe
someone's former profession and you
start to connect things and you realize
oh as does our main hero she's
terrific I loved her as a protagonist
she was a lot of fun to root for and you
can actually root for her because she's
smart the other guy that's trapped down
there is played by John Gallagher jr.
who gives a really good performance they
did attempt to give him a back story of
one scene to kind of flesh him out but
he is unfortunately that character that
doesn't get the attention the other two
characters do and so he's not very
compelling the film is really about Mary
Elizabeth Winstead and John Goodman and
these two facing off and what really is
going on there because we don't really
know and that's one of the things I
loved about this movie is the fact that
you walk into it not knowing anything
thank goodness now in such a small and
confined location your average director
might have a hard time coming up with
new ways to make each scene interesting
not the case here there's always
something to be concerned about there's
always a new door
affection to every scene in which you
feel on edge and that is awesome because
you really are very limited in this film
and what you could actually do at least
for the majority of it now I do have
some cons and one of them is that I'm
not entirely sure the use of the
Cloverfield name and the title was
warranted because there isn't much to
connect it in fact there's really only
one line in the entire film that I could
sense that there was some connection
it's not necessarily a spoiler for this
movie but it is a spoiler if I explain
it for the last film so after I give my
grade for this movie I am going to
discuss this one line and if you don't
want any spoilers at all even the most
mild one for this film it does however
spoil the first I'll wait until after I
get my grade so what I'm saying is that
some fans may go to this movie
disappointed because the Cloverfield
monster doesn't really have anything to
do with this movie it's just a movie
about captivity and it works brilliantly
I mean it's a great thriller I loved
this movie and I want to see it again
right now but some people who want to
see a raging monster or something along
those lines could be disappointed with
this movie also there is a third act
reveal that I of course will not ruin
for you and it did feel rushed it does
come up very fast and it sort of leaves
you going like whoa like that was just
really abrupt and it worked for me after
some thought while I was watching and I
was like I don't know about this but I
sat down I took a lot of notes and I
thought about the movie and I thought
about things that were said previously
in the movie I thought about sounds that
I heard previously in the film
I thought about small hints that were
given by certain characters in the film
and I realized that it might be a first
viewing problem one of those things
where when you see the movie for the
first time you don't know what to expect
and then you see what the film is
building to and it's sort of like you
have to process it you really have to
think about it and afterthought I
appreciated it even more and that is the
only issue I have with JJ Abrams
marketing I love the fact that you never
know anything but it always creates an
expectation and that expectation can
sometimes make you really dislike a film
because you create these god-like
heavenly expectations in your head
because you really don't know what his
films are about or films that his
production company are involved in he
mystery box as he calls it it's a
brilliant marketing technique but
sometimes when you see the film you're
like oh well that wasn't exactly what I
expected
don't go into this movie with any
expectations expect a fun thriller that
is actually very scary on a human level
very small which is a huge plus because
usually sequels or prequels or reboots
within a franchise think well we have to
make it huge this time because the last
one was this big this film does the
exact opposite makes it smaller and in
that way I loved 10 Cloverfield Lane and
I cannot wait to see it again I'm going
to give this film and a will some people
go to this movie expecting a certain
film not get it and say it's horrible
yes don't go into this film expecting
Cloverfield to expect a thriller and you
will get one so like I said mild mild
spoiler for this film heavy spoiler for
the first Cloverfield so if you've never
seen the first Cloverfield just you know
I'm about to say some here the
final shot of the first Cloverfield
which by the way I watched last night
and still loved far in the background
you see the ocean and you see a small
little dot falling from the sky landing
in the ocean a lot of people got really
excited when this was discovered back in
2008 because it's extremely easy to miss
this is a satellite now apparently that
satellite is what disturbed the
Cloverfield monster from its sleep in
the ocean that's like the big Easter egg
on the first Cloverfield movie and
apparently the reason the Cloverfield
monster arose from the ocean that
satellite in this new film John Goodman
mentions that his previous profession
involved working with satellites that's
the only connection I can find which is
very minor and it might not even be a
connection but I do find it very
coincidental and it has to mean
something
because rarely is anything ever put in a
JJ Abrams production that's specific if
it doesn't mean something guys those are
my thoughts on this film do check it out
I do think it's worth your time I
appreciated the effort these filmmakers
made also I just want to thank everyone
who bought my book I'm seriously just
blown away you guys are amazing and I
owe you so much thanks I do want to
mention in case for some who perhaps are
a different country who are not able to
get the book the e-book is currently
available on Amazon
so that's cool for you guys if you still
want to read it in some way on the
Internet and then just thank you so much
for buying that it really means the
world to me it was a dream come true
please stay tuned this Sunday because my
friend John Flickinger aka the flick pic
and I are about to ravage Superman for
the quest for peace you guys are the
best thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck with
niced